while Naya Rivera became a primetime
strongly but her life off-screen has
been filled with more drama than
anything on that show an eating disorder
plastic surgery and she even faced one
of the most emotional decisions any
woman could ever make
Michelle Turner visited and I at home
where she opened up about everything you
found out you were pregnant you made a
decision not to keep the baby do you
still think about it today absolutely I
think it's it's it's always on your mind
and it's one of those like little skies
in life it was 2010 Naya had just broken
up with her boyfriend Ryan Dorsey the
then 23 year old had the abortion on her
one day off from shooting Glee what was
the main reason why you decided to have
the abortion there's a bunch of
different factors you know when I was
just so young Naya doesn't hold back in
her new tell-all sorry not sorry
I'll set makeouts a sex Dan apartment
it's all in there including the drama
between her and co-star Lea Michele you
felt like she was unprofessional
definitely on the same definitely in
high school nya struggle with anorexia
at 18 she got breast implants despairing
no detail she even addresses her past
engagement to Big Sean you found ariana
grande in his home when you all were
still together he had a home studio
downstairs so you know it's not like
anything was crazy when I went there you
don't think anything was going on I know
two of them while you were together I
don't think so no if we would have ended
up getting married it would have ended
like probably a month later today nya
and Ryan are married and parents too
almost one year old son Josie who gets
to have playdates with another glee baby
you have playdates with Heather's yeah
Heather I just saw Heather two weekends
ago we took the boys around the corner
you love being a mommy oh my gosh she
always greets me with a smile and it's
just so amazing to see you want more uh
yeah I would probably
have another Oh so do you maybe maybe -
are you trying no I don't know we're not
trying yet no you're like no let me know
my mom is about to turn 30 needs a
couple more cocktails when we do that I
love the honesty well now I'm not the
only